[Música]
vivimos sobre estimulados a la palabra
liderazgo por todo sitio nos arrojan
mensajes en cursos talleres donde me
dicen conviértete en el líder debes de
ser el líder tienes que ser el líder
tienes que estar ahí arriba y la
realidad es que nos damos cuenta que la
mayor parte del tiempo de mi día soy un
seguidor y no hay cursos talleres ni
siquiera amigos que me digan cómo debo
de seguir
y que es un vaquero entre botas y
sombrero cuestionando estos temas pues
bien
quiero compartirles que llevo 12 años de
mi vida analizando a diario el
comportamiento la lógica y en especial
las emociones de los caballos y dentro
de este análisis me han dado grandes
lecciones de liderazgo y de inteligencia
emocional pero antes de analizarlas
quiero que paremos un segundo y pensemos
que toda nuestra historia ha sido
escrita gracias a ellos estamos en este
sitio gracias a ellos nos han ayudado a
conquistar territorios nos han ayudado a
transportarnos nos hemos ocupado como
animales de carga y yo sí creo que es
tiempo de evitar todo el abuso con el
que viven es tiempo de aprender para
ellos pero en especial para nosotros
mismos como especie
soy kervin leon y soy formador ecuestre
me dedico a crear un vínculo entre los
humanos y los caballos ya sean empresas
familias organizaciones o personas al
final esto no es un deporte lo que yo
hago no se monta no lleva sillas no
llevas frenos o riendas
qué llevas únicamente tu intuición tu
instinto al caballo no le importa quién
eres cómo te llamas tu cargo tu título
tu currículum no le importa si vienes
del pop si vienes vestido o el reloj que
tengas en la mano a él sólo le interesa
lo que en este momento le estás haciendo
sentir
el caballo dice el maestro pop paraná
man es un espejo de tu alma a veces te
gustará lo que mires y otras veces no
pero te enseña a trabajar contigo mismo
piénsenlo así para entenderlo el caballo
es un animal de un promedio de 500 kilos
pero es un conejito enorme y pesado pero
al final es una y nosotros los
depredadores a pesar de que dándole
brinquemos al cuello y lo desgarremos
con las garras y nos lo comamos vivo
seguimos los depredadores y es nuestra
programación base en cómo le pides un
caballo que confíe en el león como le
pides que confíe más allá que en sus
propios instintos el caballo debe
detectar en ti un conjunto de cualidades
aptas de seguir cuales son liderazgo
confianza empatía sensibilidad
honestidad y si no la tienes no va a
confiar en ti
dentro de todo este esta experiencia he
sido testigo de grandes reprogramas
emocionales de grandes trabajos de
liderazgo y quiero compartirles cómo
funciona su liderazgo pero antes quiero
que definamos todos porque creo que no
tenemos un concepto claro de liderazgo
nos han enseñado mucho la diferencia
entre líder y patrón o jefe pero el
concepto y la filosofía de liderazgo
todavía no la tenemos clara en una sola
frase entendemos la xi para compararlo
con los caballos el liderazgo es seguido
y los cargos son obedecidos nosotros
somos una especie que ha sido programada
para obedecer cargos
hazlo porque soy tu padre hazlo porque
soy tu madre
hazlo porque soy tu maestro y si no no
apruebas hazlo porque para eso te pago
si no lo quieres hacer tengo 30 personas
atrás de ti que lo van a hacer por la
mitad de tu sueldo entonces obedecemos
cargos y si todavía cuestionan que
estemos programados a obedecer cargos no
conozco un solo niño que tiende a su
cama y diga si mamá sabe lo que es bueno
para mí
y ambiente de sus cobertores felizmente
y ustedes lo conocen cuestionen porque
usualmente tiendo cama porque después va
a la paleta porque después me llevan al
parque o porque después hay helado y la
realidad es que desde niños no
aprendemos a seguir no aprendemos a
confiar dentro de este concepto el
liderazgo de los caballos quiero
compartir tres pilares que yo considero
aptos de seguir y aprender de ellos y
son experiencia emoción y confianza así
que analicemos cada uno de ellos la
experiencia como aprenden bajo
experiencia a los caballos
si yo caballo me tropiezo con lodo o
fango
voy a generar una experiencia de ello y
durante toda mi vida no podía volver a
pisar el lodo porque sé que me tropecé y
me hizo daño y si es sumamente necesario
voy a tomar las medidas para pasar
despacio y no perjudicar me
cuando yo convierto
un error en experiencia automáticamente
deja de ser un error así viven los
caballos como vivo yo hoy felizmente
caminando y me encuentro una piedra
y me tropiezo con ella teóricamente tuve
que haber aprendido de ese tropiezo
entonces vuelvo a recorrer mi camino
vuelvo a encontrarme con la piedra y
vuelvo a tropezar
hoy por la tercera teóricamente ya debía
haber aprendido
vuelvo a recorrer mi camino me paro
frente a la piedra ahora si la veo y
digo
no me volví a tropezar con la piedra
por hay de la cuarta o quinta le agarró
amor a la piedra y cuidado con esas
piedras tóxicas a las que le agarran
amor
entonces si todavía no aprendo de mi
experiencia déjenme compartirles otro
ejemplo si yo le pongo un caballo un
barril de tequila y un barril de agua
que creen que beba
para oler el tequila para saber que no
le deja nada bueno y entonces va a beber
agua
durante toda su vida no va a volver al
tequila
qué hacemos como humanos
y en el viernes
me voy al bar me tomo 2 o 30 cervecitas
inmediatamente pierdo el equilibrio
pierdo la consciencia
pierdo el celular
pierdo la dignidad
a veces no pierdo el celular pero pierdo
la dignidad por lo que escribo desde el
celular
al otro día sábado despierto
la peor cruda resaca de mi vida
sintiéndome malísimo y que digo
no lo va a ser
y genere un aprendizaje
y entonces llega el viernes y voy al
mismo bar me tomo las mismas cervezas
ahora con un celular nuevo
y vuelvo embriagarme
quién es el lógico aquí
quién es el racional
analicemos el segundo pilar que son las
emociones y antes de compartirles cómo
funcionan los caballos quiero que todos
aquí entendamos que las emociones se van
a un subconsciente y las aprendo para
siempre se me quedan para siempre
conocimiento no el conocimiento se
olvida hagamos un ejercicio rápido
recuerden su última graduación cuando
les entregaron su título o su diploma
justo ese momento en el que toman el
documento y se los dan en la mano que
sintieron
puede ser miedo porque no sé qué sigue
puede ser satisfacción y liberación
porque ya terminé
pero estoy seguro que recuerdan esa
emoción pero si yo les digo cuál fue su
última materia o cuál fue su último
hombre del tema estoy seguro que nos
recuerdan porque es conocimiento y el
conocimiento se olvida así que pensemos
cómo aprenden los caballos si un potro
empieza a alterar la armonía de la
manada empieza a comportarse mal o
travieso estaría provocando llamarle al
león y decirle aquí estamos van a
comernos entonces qué hace las mamás o
las tías lo agarran a patadas firmemente
y lo sacan de la manada entonces el otro
sale
genera un miedo y una angustia terrible
porque si yo estoy solo y aparece el
león a quien se van a comer
entonces regresa dice lo siento mamá no
lo vuelva a hacer y quizás no diga lo
siento pero si entiende cuál fue la
experiencia y durante toda su vida no lo
va a volver a hacer ahora pensemos en
los papás y las mamás de tres tiempos y
se identifican si es así
piénsenlo así
juniors llevas una hijo
juniors papá llevas 12 te estoy viendo
junio no quieres conocer el 3 verdad
mira ya va a llegar el 3 y va a saber
y no es cierto nunca llega el 3 no hay
un establecimiento del límite no hay una
emoción generada y no hay un aprendizaje
así que yo sí creo que es tiempo de
aprender de las emociones de los
caballos y aprender a gestionar las
nuestras porque nos han dicho cuando nos
enojamos tranquilo tranquilo no hagas
nada respira no te des quites y el enojo
se tiene que canalizar y zona y nos han
enseñado que cuando estamos tristes y
bajo melancolía hay no desquita te si te
dejo ver es quítate porque estás triste
la tristeza simplemente se vive así que
los caballos nos permiten hacernos
conscientes de la gestión de mis
emociones y así es como aprenden
el tercer pilar
la confianza
vivimos en una sociedad donde nos han
creado el paradigma de no confíes en
nadie
no es bueno confiar los caballos desde
que nacen
el potro tiene que confiar en la manada
porque además si llevas 20 o 25 años en
esta vida donde somos los animales presa
algo estás haciendo bien si yo pudiera
voltear y decir eso que hizo me funcionó
le funcionó a él me va a funcionar a mí
eso que hizo no le funcionó puede que no
me funcione a mí pero hemos vivido y nos
hemos creado el paradigma de decir nadie
escarmienta en cabeza ajena y entonces
nos justificamos diciendo oh sí lo tenía
que equivocarme para aprender sí porque
a todos nos pasa y la realidad que
hacemos a un lado el cúmulo de
experiencias de las personas mayores de
las personas que ya vivieron y que
conocen el camino y no sabemos seguir
no sabemos confiar después de estos tres
pilares de liderazgo ahora entiendo la
frase del maestro break hand y si algo
puedo compartirles desde el alma y que
se lleven de esta charla es esta frase
sé tan suave como sea posible pero tan
firme como sea necesario
esta frase nos enseña a ser asertivos sé
tan suave como sea posible nos enseña
que no necesito gritar que no necesito
exigir que no necesito alzar la voz
puedo ser suave puedo ser tierno puedo
pedirle amablemente
y a contraparte se tan firme como sea
necesario
cuando yo establezco un límite
me enseña que ser firme no significa ser
injusto
pero vivimos en una sociedad donde nos
culpamos y nos victimizamos por decir no
es que me caigo gordo pero como le voy a
decir que no como no voy a ir entonces
nos vivimos bajo honestidad y confianza
así que se tan suave como sea posible
pero tan firme como sea necesario
y les quiero compartir un último
análisis de la lógica del caballo
su estructura cerebral no le permite
tener sentido del pasado y no le permite
tener sentido de futuro es solo está
presente aquí y ahora y es una gran
lección que nosotros como humanos
debemos aprender yo les apuesto que si
en ese momento las un caballo en estado
salvaje y lo encierro en una caballeriza
de tres por tres les aseguro que no se
victimiza y empieza a y madre mía porque
a mí y mis 47 hectáreas de alfalfa y
1.025 yeguas preciosas no es cierto está
aquí y ahora quizá no disfrutando el
momento pero sí aceptándolo y
aprendiendo de él
nosotros tenemos depresión por exceso de
pasado y ansiedad por exceso de futuro y
se nos ha olvidado estar presentes aquí
y ahora
piénsenlo tenemos depresión porque ya
llevo el lunes y tenemos ansiedad porque
llegue el viernes cuantos de aquí odian
sus lunes
porque les voy a dar un dato duro si
ustedes odian sus lunes estarían odiando
un promedio de 10 años de su vida
así que consideren
yo sí creo que es tiempo de aprender de
ellos yo sí creo que se puede liderar en
paz y seguir bajo confianza así que se
los digo baja tu liderazgo respira
no tienes que ser el líder
no tienes que estar ahí ser seguidor no
te convierte en borrego ser seguidor te
armoniza en un sistema así que siéntete
aquí y ahora y hace responsable
si no confías en tu líder
cambiarte de manada